lo que quiero realizar en este vídeo es
darte bastantes propiedades de límites
pero no las voy a probar rigurosamente
en esta ocasión o en el orden que
normalmente se prueban dichas
propiedades con la definición rigurosa
de lo que el límite significa sino más
bien lo que vamos a realizar en dicho
tutorial es que no es tanto con las
definiciones de epsilon si deltas de los
límites sino más bien de una forma que
nos resulte bastante intuitiva y muy
útil a la vez para futuros problemas de
límites entonces tenemos aquí que el
límite de fx cuando el que se aproxima
hace va a ser igual a l y luego por acá
que el límite de otra función de x
cuando x aproxima c es igual a m
entonces dado esto cuál será el límite
de fx + gx cuando x se aproxima a c y
bueno espero lo puedas visualizar porque
pues no tenemos aquí gráficas y son
simplemente funciones en general
entonces esto sería igual a simplemente
separar el límite y lo voy a repetir una
vez más esto no es una prueba rigurosa
es un tanto intuitiva entonces esto es
igual al límite
de fx cuando x aproxima hace más el
límite de gx la otra función cuando x
aproxima a c y esto a su vez sabemos que
este límite de por aquí como arriba lo
pusimos y lo voy a poner de mismo o de
diferente color es igual a l y luego
entonces este límite de la función de x
es igual a m entonces sería la suma de
los límites y pues no fue complicado
esto de aquí finalmente es llamada la
regla de la suma de los límites y ahora
más adelante tenemos algo muy similar
pero con un poco de diferencia entonces
lo que nos va a decir es que el límite
cuando x aproxima hace de fx menos
- gx va a ser igual a la resta de los
límites tenemos el límite de la resta va
a ser igual a la resta de los límites
que sabíamos que uno por una parte es n
menos el otro que es m y bueno como
puedes darte cuenta esto de verdad
resulta intuitivo no es tan complicado y
ahora hay que pasar con el producto de
dos funciones entonces tenemos que el
límite
de fx por gd x el producto cuando x se
aproxima a c con suerte esto va a ser
igual al límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a c por el límite de la función
g de x cuando x aproxima hace que a su
vez también como habíamos visto
anteriormente arriba el límite de fx lo
vamos a poner igual del color naranja es
igual a l por el límite de gx que es
igual a m entonces nos queda que el
límite del producto es igual al producto
de los límites entonces esto nos
representa nuestra tercera regla y pasa
lo mismo si tuviéramos una función por
una constante entonces tenemos que el
límite de la constante k por fx cuando x
aproxima a c esto va a ser igual a tener
lo mismo que acá que es la constante por
el límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a c
donde el límite de fx cuando x aproximas
es igual a l entonces nos queda
simplemente el producto de la constante
el límite que es el y esta es conocida
como la regla de la constante que en
realidad es como la del producto pero
con la pequeña diferencia de que acá es
constante es una función constante y
entonces ahora vamos a cuando tenemos un
cociente tenemos el límite de fx sobre
gdx cuando x se aproxima a c y esto va a
ser igual a tener el límite en la parte
del numerador de fx cuando se aproximase
sobre el límite de eje x cuando x
aproxima a c y entonces también sabemos
que esto es igual a l y en la parte de
abajo sabemos que esto es igual al m
entonces nos queda el cociente de l
sobre m y ésta viene siendo nuestra
cuarta propiedad nuestra propiedad donde
nos dice que el límite del cociente es
el cociente de los límites y finalmente
tenemos aquí que el límite de fx elevado
a una potencia donde la potencia va a
ser r sobre s donde ambas ambos números
van a ser enteros cuando x se aproxima a
c va a ser igual
lo siguiente este es muy conocida como
la propiedad del exponente y entonces
tenemos que es igual al límite de fx
cuando que se aproxima a c y todo esto
elevado al cociente que tenemos y dicho
conscientes y es importante que
mencionemos que ambos números son
enteros para que todo esto tenga sentido
y bueno sabemos que es el límite de fx
es igual a l y entonces lo voy a
escribir por acá abajo esto sería el
elevado la potencia del cociente de r
sobre s finalmente tú puedes ocupar
todas estas propiedades en una forma
natural para cuando te lleguen a tocar
ejemplos que las ocupen y si tienes las
gráficas esto lo haría todavía mucho más
intuitivo y mucho más fácil de
visualizar